this morning on the dish chef Craig Koo
ketsu as a teenager growing up in San
Jose California he was inspired by early
TV chefs like Julia Child and Jacques
Pepin Annie showed off his skills
cooking for friends at parties
he studied pre-law at Berkeley but found
himself more intrigued by his part-time
job at a gourmet grocery and started
considering food as a career after
graduation he worked in top restaurants
on the west coast and here in New York
he's now executive chef and partner at
quality branded creating the culinary
concept and menus for quality meets
quality Italian quality eats and Park
Avenue spring and chef great coquettes
ooh good morning welcome to the dish
thanks for having me thanks for being
here tell us about what's on this table
all right we got a nice spread for you
today this is we'll start here this is
uh what we call our monkey bread and
this was sort of like a family tradition
during the holidays my mom would sort of
put balls of dough together and then let
them rise and proof up and they'd like
your mom's tradition yeah and then these
are our long bone short rib steaks so
basically instead of raising short ribs
we take them we slice the bone
lengthwise and we grill them like a
steak we have scalps sunchokes over
there we have bacon with peanut butter
and jalapeno jelly
oh wow and then over there way over
there we have corn creme brulee oh
you're you're you were saying this a
kind of a dessert disguised as a side
exactly everybody loves dessert so if
you can manage to sneak it in before
dessert I like your cousin I love
dessert and I'm gonna go there actually
because I see we have dessert and a
fantastic drink I don't know which to go
for I would try the drink first that's
that's what we call our key money and
for those of you that are in the
restaurant business key money is
something that you sort of end up paying
a prior tenant to sort of get the space
and that's sort of a wink and a nod to
our former tenant at our space I quality
eats it was a gin mill and so that has
strawberries a good summer yes delicious
right mm-hmm and there's cucumber cubes
in there it's delicious so you started
we said we said coming in that you kind
of studied at the school of Julia Child
there's a whole class of chefs it seems
that she essentially graduated through
her TV show deaf
you know I think that was sort of this
was like pre Food Network and so PBS was
sort of like your only source of all
this information about food and Julia
was like was like the Queen and I would
what attracted you to it I think it
started early in life I was I come from
a large family six kids so my my mom and
my dad by the time they got to me I was
a youngest of six they really were
pretty easygoing about being in the
kitchen and I was sort of standing on
top of a chair at the stove and I always
felt comfortable so it seemed like a
natural transition for me to sort of do
it as a as a profession yet you started
off pre-law in college when did you know
that was that was the biggest mistake I
could never actually it's the biggest
mistake I avoided so yeah I was I was
studying rhetoric at Cal Berkeley and
and it was a pre-law major I don't
really know what I was doing but I
quickly found out that we've all had
those moments yeah I was I was
outclassed by my my my fellow classmates
so and my interest turned towards food I
was working in a grocery store at that
time and we had chefs coming through and
I was talking to them about produce and
and they were talking to me about what
they would do with it and I was just
really intrigued so it I was just sort
of drawn to it yeah some minimum-wage
jobs you were working in kitchens but
what was sort of that first real get
where you were able to really focus on
the food what was that job for you well
I think when I moved to New York and I
got into the kitchen of lespinasse and
this was in the 90s and chef gray Kunz
was the chef and it was just it was so
far beyond anything I had experienced to
that point his mixture of French
technique and all these like really
exotic Asian ingredients and Indian
spices and it was it was that was like
opened up for me what cooking could be
you preside you were telling us now over
eight restaurants right soon to be a
nine soon to be nine yeah we're opening
another one in Manhattan
early July I'm always amazed at how you
keep something like that going it's it's
a lot of work but really you know it's
like anything it's it's building a good
team again we have an amazing team we
have people that have been with us for
in our company for like close to 40
years our company goes back way way back
to 1977 with Smith Malinsky mm-hmm and
so so you know we have people that have
been with us for that entire time and
those people are really what keeps us
going it is amazing just the work that
you're doing and also the idea of taking
these larger restaurants and keeping
them
I guess feeling more casual and
comfortable how do you do that um well
it's again it's your employees you know
you have to be able to make people feel
like they're a true guest like they're
in your home they're coming to your
house oh and that's how we treat them
you know everybody matters you know and
and if you can get that across to your
employees and they can get that across
to the guests then you're going to have
a great restaurant well it is the dish
so we want you to sign and as you're
signing let me ask you if you could have
a meal with anyone past or present who
would it be I would have to say my mom I
don't really get together enough with
her and I think she'd be really proud of
and she doesn't really get out to the
East Coast so she'd be really proud to
see you know what we've accomplished out
here mama is always a good choice it is
and it is all delicious chef chef Craig
Kotetsu thank you very much we
appreciate you being here for more on
Craig and the dish you can head to our
website at CBS this morning calm